this was a boy let down neglected and
failed by A system that was supposed to
protect him a wabashak just turned two
before he died in December 2020 from a
severe respiratory condition caused by
this
mold and damp engulfed the one bedroom
flat where he lived with his family in
every room the black fungus led to a wob
having severe breathing difficulties but
despite the family's repeated complaints
since 2017 nothing was done to protect
him almost two years on from his death
and today a coroner ruled action to
treat and prevent the mold wasn't taken
outside the court awab's mum and dad had
a message for those responsible we
shouted out as loudly as we could but
despite making all those efforts every
night we will be coming back to the same
problem stop discriminating stop being
racist stop providing unfair treatment
to people coming from a grad stop
housing people in homes you know are
unfit for human habitation but it was
the coroner's comments which will Echo
across the housing sector throughout the
country
how does this happen how in the UK in
2020 does a two-year-old child die due
to exposure to mold Miss Kearsley said
this issue is not simply a Rochdale
problem nor is damp and mold simply a
social housing problem it is a
significant issue in private sector too
there is little doubt that the tragic
death of a wabashak will and should be a
defining moment for the housing sector
issues of mold and damp are still a
major problem on this estate inside some
of the flats we've visited living
conditions are incredibly poor and the
news of the coroner's conclusion is a
worry for many
nasif was too embarrassed to show his
face but he wanted us to see how he's
been living for the last eight years
with the mold affecting his health too
he told me it's really terrible to live
here how on Earth can a normal person
live in a flat like this it's really
difficult and in another five or ten
years if I carry on living here I think
I'll be dead too the Housing Association
told us they've tried to gain access to
the flat and will urgently contact
Nassif again to carry out treatment
works but responding to a wabashak's
family's accusations and the coroner's
findings Rochdale Borough whitehousing
did not apologize for their mistakes
they said as a community-owned
organization we support the diverse
communities of Rochdale we must make
sure this can never happen again awab's
death needs to be a wake-up call for
everyone in housing social care and
health
awab was a boy full of smiles life and
laughter but whilst his death leaves a
huge void his family are hoping it isn't
in vain in saman Rashid Sky News
Rochdale